my name
[Music]
in determining how Neymar should fly we
wanted to make sure that his flight
patterns in motion was different than
any of the other characters we've seen
flying in the past we were trying to
come up with ways that when he flew that
he would feel powerful and intimidating
and that did boil down to trying to
develop Wings on his feet that felt
really real that felt like they could
generate enough thrust to sort of push
him through the air and through the
water
so we kind of explored flight Motion in
birds and we kind of landed in a world
that was probably combining the flight
patterns of hummingbirds along with
larger birds of prey that was kind of
step one step two then was how do we
make his movement differ and how can we
connect it again back to things that
were somewhat used to so we looked at
how a helicopter moves we looked at
track and field as well so triple jumps
one of the things that Ryan cooler
brought was parkour he liked the idea of
the winged feet being something that
felt like he was stepping through the
air and pushing off of them
I was also really interested because
he's so intrinsically tied to water the
idea that whatever downward force was
coming off of those wings would use the
water to Showcase how much power was
actually blowing off of the Wings
so this was a live action set and stunts
had a wire rig that had two pick points
on tenoch's Stunt Devil's hips and then
the wires pick him up as he takes two
steps as he then takes off and then at a
certain point we transition from the
Practical element to a CG character
the part that I'm most proud of looking
back at all the work that we did on
Namor was the collaboration between the
artists and the supervisors at ilm with
Ryan and the filmmakers here at Marvel
Studios and the result that we came up
with together I think is a is a super
fun idea and it was so much fun to try
and accomplish
[Music]
thank you